- I don't think I've
ever had Israeli food,
but I also don't know
what food I have had.
So, you pronounce it "peter's guitar"?
- [Man in Stripes] Peter's
guitar, I love peter's guitar.
- Look at how good these look!
- They love the sesame seeds!
- Kinda looks like a quiche-y pizza.
- Mm-kay, that was a work out.
- It's really good, except they forgot
the sauce, the cheese, and the pepperoni.
- It's pretty dry.
- Does it come with any dipping sauces?
- It tastes like dust.
- Israeli Cheeto dust.
- Yeah, it should be more like pizza.
- [Man in White Shirt] Whoa, what?
- [Man in Stripes] Look at this!
Look how cool it is!
It's a croissant.
- With sesame seeds.
- They over-invested in
sesame seeds one year,
and they're like, "We're just
gonna use it on everything."
- This is our main export, sesame seed.
- Let's "sesame see"
how well they stay on.
- I'm gonna leave.
- Oh, it's flaky, I appreciate that.
- You like flaky things?
- Rule number one to making Israeli food,
it has to crumble everywhere.
- Is there something in it?
- A big block of cheese in the middle.
- (gasps) Oh, that's where the magic is!
- Oh my god, breakfast,
lunch, and dinner, please!
- I would love to dip it
in some marinara sauce.
- Do I have food all over my face?
- No.
- Cool.
- [Man in White Shirt] Sabikh!
Like a bird beak.
- [Man in Stripes] So finally,
it's got a lot of things going on.
- Now this looks scary.
- It's not the nicest looking thing.
- It's like a sandwich that
you left in your lunch bag
and then sat on it, or something.
- Do we use our hands?
- Whole medley of stuff in here.
- Yeah, it is just burstin'
at the seams with gooey stuff.
- This is basically like a
five-course meal within a pita.
(girl laughs)
- That's a lot of meals.
- One culinary journey
I do not want to go on.
- It's like a Hot Pocket, but good.
- For me, this is a winner.
- Go Isreal.
- [Man in White Shirt and
Man in Stripes] Shakshouka!
- [Man in Stripes] The famous Marvel hero.
- This looks Italian.
- That's just because it's red.
- I can't say I'm a fan
of the presentation.
- Ehh...
- Look at this thingy!
- We won't need these spoons.
- Oh, no!
- The texture is weird.
- This looks like an eyeball!
- I see eggs.
- Ooh, ooh!
- I love it.
- It's spicy.
- You know what?
Tastes exactly what it looks like.
- Did you wash your hands before this?
- No.
- "Israeli" good!
(girl laughs)
- [Together] ♫ More food, more
food, more Israeli, Israeli,
- ♫ Food, food, more
food, more food, Israeli
♫ food food, more food
♫ I want more Israeli food
♫ Give some more, more food, yeah ♫